hello everyone and welcome to another
matchup you've all been waiting for it's
the quarterfinals of the feeder World
Cup 2019 Alexandria vs. King ding again
it's it's a really a peculiar game but a
very exciting one as usual because we
only shows so very nice games here
without further ado let's check it out
of course we have D for the Queens
gambit declined we'll be on the board we
have Knight to f6 c4 e6 Knight to f3 and
d5 so the Queen's got me the client is
on the board and the g3 preparing to
fianchetto the LightSquared Bishop and D
captures on c4 will Bishop to G to the
Catalan opening and now a6 with castles
by Gary shook and now Knight to c6 and
here III defending the d4 pawn and the
dingos rook to b8 and now preparing to
well getting the rock out of this nasty
there you know and also preparing to
push b5 at the protective spawn and now
Knight f2 d2 by going after the c4 pawn
if you're wondering why not
this Knight here because well why not
develop another piece is because now
black can put b5 so you cannot capture
it
Knight f2 d2 whereas after going after
the c4 pawn now you cannot play b5 as
the knight on c6 hangs so night after d2
back Bishop and now II five being
decides to open up the center with
Bishop captures and c6 with check D
captures and now D captures on e5 this
is all all has been played before we
have Knight to g4 preparing to recapture
on e5 and now only Knight captures on c4
with Bishop to e6 biding attacking the
knight on c4 and now Quinta e to getting
the night out of the way and now h5
defending his his Knight so now the
bishop will be able to capture on c4 and
here we've looked d1 attacking dings
Queen and there has been only one game
that reached this position where Queen
to e7 was played by the Dean plays Queen
to see it is the strongest move
recommended by the engine and well no
doubt being prepared this line very
nicely for good Ashok
and it's very interesting what happens
in the next move
so here it's a completely new game
already as of move 13 and the Grisha
plays Queen to f3 Queen to f3 with the
idea of course that if dingos for the
night here with Bishop captures and c4
then Queen captures and c6 just wins the
game
it's check you have to move the King
King g7 now you play b3 and you will
very nicely
well deliver checkmate after Bishop to
e3 or black will have to suffer severe
material losses the problem is after
this Queen to f3 move ding doesn't have
to capture the night Queen to f3 is
actually a losing move forged issue
which is incredible as the losing move
happened at the head exactly at the
moment when they left
well the known theory as the Quinta CA
tis a new move by ding and the grecian
replies with Queen to f3 the losing move
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the the refutation of Queen
to f3 while I give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations on finding on
finding a line that King ding missed in
the game and for those of you who just
won't enjoy the show it's Bishop to d5
and here white would have to give up the
rook for the bishop with rook captures
on d5 we're gonna show that line but the
just in case you don't believe me here's
what happens if you decide to well to
protect your queen for example it and
pushing efore doesn't work then you just
capture the knight and the Queen no
longer has access to the c6 bone so
let's say you move the Queen back Queen
back to e2 now you continue the attack
h4 and now with the Queen threatening to
come to h3 after the knight moves you
can see the bishop also eyes this
diagonal now after H captures and g3 the
rook will also open up it's just
impossible for whites to fend off all of
the threats for example if f3 you just
ignore that and continue H captures in
g3 the rook is now coming to h2 so you
have to play H captures and g3 but still
rook to h2 and now if the Queen moves
for example Queen to d3 now you play
Bishop captures on f3 and the rook to h1
will be made
there's nothing nothing you can do about
this so after this Bishop to b5 move
it's very ill-advised to move the Queen
what's better is just rook captures on
d5 and this offers a lot more play for
example she captures Queen captures in
the now Queen to f5 now Dean goes after
the f2 pawn and you have to calculate
everything after what happens after
Queen to c6 check King to d8 and Queen
back to g2 now there is no continuation
to the attack the problem with the
position is that the grease of species
are still undeveloped so you have to go
back to defend and now h4 again you're
you're busting the Kings side open
doesn't matter if you play h3 f3
whatever you play three just H captures
in g3 you continue the attack and after
F captures and g3 you go Knight captures
on e5 going for Knight to f3 and well if
Knight captures Queen captures you have
this position where the Grisha problem
is that his pieces are undeveloped and
your plan your you're gonna play Bishop
to d6 you're gonna threaten to capture
here the rope is coming into the game
it's very hard for white to develop to
develop you if you play Knight here
you're gonna lose the e3 pawn you don't
really have a good way to develop the
bishop if you develop it you you could
lose the b2 point as both the rook and
the Queen are attacking it so it would
be a winning position for ding but it's
too much to calculate and ding did not
play ding didn't go back up to d5 dink
went rook the b6
he doesn't like this Queen to have to
remove with the idea of Queen captures
here as dings King is still in the
center and well there are a lot of
pieces around this black King you kind
of don't do if you don't find Bishop to
d5 you don't really have all that many
movies you can play but okay
dink played rook the b6 he defended the
c6 pony he offered the exchange defend
of the attack and also to fix his pawn
structure on the Queen side and okay
Rishel captured we have Knight capture C
captures and now the Queen also defends
the c6 pawn so there is no threat of
Queen captures and c6 and now ding just
continues the attack we have h4 sorry h4
by Greece rocky he prevented him from
continuing the attack by playing gauge
for
being placed Knight captures on e5
attacking the Queen Queen to f4 going
after the night and now Knight to g6
just pushing the Queen back Quinta efore
and now Bishop to e7 preparing the
castle and finally our Grisha
grabs a moment to start developing his
pieces we have Knight to c3 and now
Bishop to f5 pushing the Queen further
back and you kind of have to go all the
way back I will either g2 or f3 or h1
summer and along this diagonal if you
put something like Queen d4 it seems
like a nice centralizing move but then
Bishop to g4 could be somewhat annoying
your rook is under attack if you move it
you get Bishop to f3 and now you could
face some serious issues here so after
the shift f5 we have quinta h1 by Griff
shock and now nice thief I've a lot of
light square weaknesses here around the
White King and the ding of course would
like to capitalize on that
so f3 covering some of the lights were
weaknesses so Bishop to g4 followed by
Knight f3 for example when that will not
be allowed and now Bishop the c2 forcing
reshipped
either move with the rook away from the
open D file or to block his bishop
development which is what the issue does
and now the retreats with Bishop to g6
so here still Agra shock is up in
material but his pieces aren't doing all
that much and he really has to take care
of this bishop Queen to g2 by grecian
grecian we have a castles biding and now
comes rogue back to d1 he again has to
waste a move he wants to play E for he
wants to get his Bishop into the game
and finally get his other look into the
game as well with Queen to f5 by dink
now threatening to capture on f3 with
check and rook to f1 the roof is not
defending the pawn and now Queen back to
e6 and finally we have night Stewie to
preparing Knight to f4 the to go for
some more trades we have Knights to d3
now covering the f4 square but also
pressuring the b2 pawn if the bishop for
example moves at some point with King to
h2 improving the safety of the King and
now rooked d8 developing his final rook
and the only rook and E for now dink and
finally Grisha can finally develop his
lights for Bishop and then get the rope
into the game
we have f5 biding he wants the well the
the pawns around the Greeks King aren't
all that great and the ding definitely
wants to open up the position s he still
has the bishop repair which we can use
to attack the White King with he
captures an f5 Queen captures on f5 and
now Knight to f4 are going after the
bishop and the knight of course he agree
she wants dink to capture here so he can
just develop with Bishop captures and
now the rook can finally enter the game
ding is not interested he moves the
Bishop Bishop to f7 now the night is
controlled but agree shoot raise it so
it's you know irrelevant we have Knight
captures on d3 rook captures on d3 again
pressuring the f3 pawn and now still how
do you develop the bishop it's not easy
you can develop it here you can develop
it to e3 you could go g5 although it
comes with the price of a pawn so
instead the Grisha was a bishop to f4
but still it still comes with the price
of a point that should captures an h4
now and you can't capture the bishop if
you capture it then just Queen captures
here with check after King - h1 Bishop
d5 and it's game over you cannot defend
the f3 pawn anymore so we have look a to
d1 ignoring the bishop and now ding
trades with rook after sandy won rook
captures and e1 and Bishop back to f6
we have b3 and now the bishop pair will
will be able to do some nice damage and
the dink continues the attack we have g5
attacking the bishop and now Bishop the
c7 going after the b6 pawn with Bishop
to b5 biding honing in on that f3 pawn
and here Queen to e to our grisha allows
the dean to capture on f3 as it would be
followed by a perpetual check for
example if Bishop captures an f3 then
you get Queen e8 check King g7 now you
get look the d7 check King has the MU
King age 6 and now you have Queen to f8
check
there's no way to finish the attack as
the bishop does a wonderful job covering
the
squares so just king g6 you're gonna go
28 engage six Queen f8 26 and so on g8
Queen h6 Queen of fate and it would be a
draw by perpetual checks so ding ignores
the f3 point for now and he plays g4 so
what what happens here well now any
Queen to e8 checks are not all that
useful because you can always bring the
bishop back so it's a the Queen to g8
check will no longer be an option so
Queen to d3 here Grisha offers a trade
of Queens and the dinging accepts we
have Queen captures on d3 rook captures
and now G captures on f3
creating a very nice pass pawn here with
Bishop captures on b6 by Gary shook and
now Bishop to e5 and here this is move
40 both players to reach time control so
you are awarded an additional an
additional additional time on the clock
and now Goethe shook spent more than
half an hour I believe so a half an hour
or a little bit over half an hour in
this position trying to figure out of
course he's better he has he's up in the
exchange he has a look for a bishop but
he's down upon but he's still better so
he spent a lot of time here trying to
decide what to do if he could maybe
somehow try to grind this out and he
played the better of the d4 and here
being played Bishop to c4 and it was in
this position unmoved 41 that the
players agreed to a draw because even
though it seems like there's a lot to go
on here a good he should spent half an
hour and he calculated everything out
and the dink you know he wasn't just
strolling around you know minding his
own business he was also busy
calculating as it's a very important
game so here they agreed to a draw as it
is raw and we are going to show it at
the rupee's under attack you have to
move the rook while also keeping an eye
on the bishop on d4 after you move the
rook you get the shove captures the rook
captures and now f2 this is the point if
you capture the bishop you play f1 queen
so black would win so you have to go
back rook to d1 and now comes Bishop to
d3 again defending the f1 square so King
to g2 and now just f1 you bring a queen
into the game with check good would have
to give up his rook Bishop captures with
check
King captures and now you have this
position where it's King and three
points against King at reports this end
game is a draw of course both the issue
kindig know their King and ponen games
and they don't they don't need to play
the south after Bishop to b4 sorry after
Bishop t4 they agree to a draw so really
a very nice fighting draw
dink-dink really you know he enjoys a
good fight Grisha also and he didn't
find that Bishop to d5 but it's it's
always incredible I can't remember which
game it was aware mama Diarra of lost
where he just played like 22 moves
straight out of theory and then after
his opponent left I think it was against
onigiri but I can't be sure
then he just completely blundered on the
next move that was out of theory similar
was Queen to f3 it's you know Queen to
see it is a new move and then Queen to
f3 completely loses the game really just
remarkable stuff now but yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoy this first
classical game between the two of them
tomorrow we have game to where ding
we'll have the white pieces we'll see
how grief shook first then and yeah I
would like to thank such a hurry Robin
we are on Lucas Santa Rosa appeal ah
Choo glory and stone in Guin for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - in my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Phaedo
World Cup checking up on your
suggestions and so on so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day